i'm gonna be a lot harder on her so just
know that okay so then you get happy
yeah it's okay if i don't get points
hey guys what's up i'm sierra and i'm
russell wilson
and this
[Music]
i'm gonna start this thing off here
first question
what is my full name full name well name
now or this is
true what do you mean name now full name
now before you got married
no what is my full name full name now
is a sierra princess wilson but before
you were married with sierra princess
harris
he's trying to add a little extra point
don't get any bonus points i'm just
saying
all right next question where was i born
where are you born you're born in fort
hood texas don't believe wikipedia
correct okay you got another point what
is my
secret hidden talent you are actually
really good actually or like kind of
impersonating you
you can impersonate people you should do
your nicki minaj with ads for everybody
what up y'all you know it's nicki minaj
and i'm like doing whatever hanging out
with my baby
whatever doing gq couples quiz like what
yeah okay next what's my favorite meal
well you change it i mean you're
obsessed with houston's in atlanta
i'm gonna go with steak because of
because of houston's
if i got the rib eye that's one thing
what else like what i get from
you oh you guys and it's called it's the
spinach artichoke dude
okay you got another point all right uh
what is my favorite song to sing around
the house
you go and meet moods sometimes
sometimes
sometimes it's your songs level up and
so well you and cnn just did something
pretty funny there's doja cat and uh
sweetie right
i'll give you a point that's my best
friend
all right so what is the name of my
first album
first album yep well first song was
goodies
okay first album
can you give me a clue you're really
close it's not called goodies though it
wasn't that named album
i don't think okay you're gonna you
might not get a point on this but yes it
is
it's name yes it's
oh i'll give you half a point because
you got the first song right
all right next one who is my biggest
musical influence
michael jackson yeah you might get two
points he does that so quick
what is my favorite hobby what is my
favorite hobby
why i know you love traffic we'll go
travel
traveling i do i do love traveling don't
let me convince you that's not it
what is my new favorite hobby base think
about it what did i call you raving
about
oh yes skiing i'm obsessed with skinny
i'm obsessed with you like golf too much
fun i like mango
sierra i didn't say travel so is it half
a point or one point
i'm gonna give him a point because it's
one of the things that i love doing
because i'm never happy i'm gonna be a
lot harder on her so
just know that okay so then you get half
of it yeah it's okay if i don't get
points
since you want to be hard on me i gave
you an extra point on goodies
i'm gonna take that back all right
when was our first date and what did we
do well
really the first time i considered our
first date was uh
you actually were practicing you know
you're getting ready for your concert
and all that
and to pick you up he drove uh down
sunset all the way down to santa monica
and then going to the georgia hotel
there's a little like little corner
spot that we sat at and i actually took
you there
uh just recently on our anniversary but
uh that was our first little date
and that was uh the best time of my life
because
i knew that you're gonna be the one hm
it was really sweet
um okay so you get a point for that boom
all right so what is my dream travel
destination or vacation
well you've always wanted to go to
maldives yes i can't wait
for those plans i can't wait for those
plans
you get another point for that so what
is my favorite
tv show of all time all time yep
fresh prince no that is a great show
martin
bingo you get half point because i
helped you out
what are my parents first names oh okay
well carlton and jackie
i am you get another point what did i
want to be when i was a kid
yep okay where did we first say
i love you we were in dallas texas yeah
we were at [ __ ] and sam's restaurant
and that's what i told you you're all
right nick and sam's in
all right how do you know when i'm mad
at you usually you kind of do this thing
you kind of look at me
and you'll be like it is a look it's a
look and so i guess you got the point
but i wanted to give that to you
you did pretty darn good i must say and
this is how many you got right
let me see how many you get hey now
watch me do this watch me do this hey
i'm about to do this ain't no half
points on my side
uh here we go what is my full birthday
i'm gonna go quick too russell
carrington wilson
where was i born and where did i grow up
you're born in ohio
but where in ohio uh nasty cincinnati
she's going to say nasty daddy
and then you grew up in richmond
virginia do you know when i moved
that's not in the questions there who
said that's just not the part of the
question
give me the question you didn't say the
age part you were
eight months i'll give you i'll give you
that i was about
almost a year okay so you get a bonus
point
when did i first start playing football
in the league you
won a super bowl in 2014 so 2013. no i
mean like when did i first start playing
football like when i was
young oh in the league like okay
what grade level you're right second
grade um
seventh grade what did i want to be when
i was a kid
you wanted to play multiple sports you
wanted to play football and baseball
two sports okay uh what's my go-to song
pre-game
you'll like the song smile by kurt
franklin or you will like
some marvin zap i asked you what's my
go-to song i
asked you what my favorite well you do
like smile but that's not the go-to song
what's my favorite meal i know steak
would be in it and i know mac and cheese
will be in it
yes i am this is a two-part question you
gotta get involved right
what's my favorite movie what's my
favorite tv show life
is your favorite movie your favorite tv
show
game of thrones yeah good game to us
okay okay all right
i'm going to get hot streak here what
movie did i appear in 2015
um
[Music]
what's the first thing i do when i wake
up in the morning
yeah sometimes we we do it together oh
we prayed together we prayed again
we said i'm in so what cereal box did i
appear on
wings damn you got that quick okay where
did i play college football at
you played it at two colleges nc state
and wisconsin okay what's my greatest
career accomplishment
well i mean the obvious super bowl
there we go what's my what's my biggest
fear
not be prepared yeah i probably have one
that's bigger than that
was it l-o-s-i-n yes
now enough with a sentimental stuff how
many times have i made the proposals
oh you have been in the pro bowl eight
times
okay come on i need it to be harder babe
i need some
i need some more heat what's the day we
first met i'm gonna i'm
i'm going okay now you wanna go that's
the day we first met oh [ __ ]
i always mess up this one she's talking
all that stuff now she'll see if she
really remembers what's the day we first
met
march 26th okay what's the day we got
engaged
march the 11th okay last question
what was my first car and what color was
it the first car that's not on that car
is it on that car let me see if i hear
the car
no that's not that's not a part of the
game rules
your first car you had a g
okay yes okay it was a g the color of
your jeep
was eight red
six black
what i think was red it was red
so the amount of points you got uh right
here
you did pretty good man all right you
guys um i hope you all had a good time
with us
it was a blast uh obviously yeah and i
won
you know what i got some more questions
for you later